bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
alors est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
cessez le feu fragile au vu des
précédents qui ont à chaque fois été
rompu oui c'est toujours un cessez le
feu fragile mais en tout cas c'est quand
même le signe d'une du souhait de
manifester une volonté parce
qu'effectivement c'est associé de
souffle été annoncés pour trois jours
liée à l' aider à la bac et la grande
fête du sacrifice qui coïncide justement
avec avec le hajj tout ça est fortement
marqué c'est pas le premier il ya eu il
ya eu des précédents notamment même
environ 2020 il ya eu d'abord au moment
du lait il est le site fermé quelques
jours effectivement des suspensions des
combats qui et puis et puis d'ailleurs
une trêve partiel qui avaient été
entamées en février 2020 donc dans le
cas des négociations qui ont d'ailleurs
déboucher sur un accord les 29 février à
deux voies entre états unis entre les
américains et les talibans non c est
envahie à la confirmation d'un processus
et qui est difficile mais qui quand même
en cours et qui a prévoyait plusieurs
étapes justement de sortie crise parra
autour de la question afghane alors il
ya des pourparlers de paix un qui
doivent commencer manifestement la
semaine prochaine c'est un peu confus
c'est sans cesse reporté pourquoi qu'est
ce qui se passe oui c'est confus parce
que il faut rappeler que dans les
clauses de l'accord de paix de france et
voyez il y avait d'abord l'engagement
américain du retrait progressif des
treize mille hommes avec
des échéances qui était programmé
d'ailleurs ce retrait a été accéléré
puisque saint mais il restait plus que
sept mille cinq à sept mille soldats
américains
une accélération liée probablement au
qu'ovide et puis il y avait une deuxième
clause qui était la question des
délibérations d'une part de certains
talibans d'autre part de soldats qui
étaient près de prisonniers 5000 d'un
côté ni de l'autre
c'était une pierre d'achoppement qui
avait d'ailleurs bloqué le 10 mars qui
allait bouleverser le calendrier donc il
y avait différé la poursuite des
négociations
un train afghane et c'était c'est
l'enjeu principal la troisième étape
effectivement qui était prévu par le
l'accord de paix et c'est précisément la
perspective de ces négociations entre
afghans qui qui est là j'allais dire là
la porte de sortie principale a nommé
dans tu l éventuelle situation de crise
avérée aujourd'hui est donc cesser ses
langes ont effectivement actuelle qui a
été annoncé et qui qui est poussé par
les américains qui veulent accélérer
leurs autres et justement c'est d'accord
de paix 1 c'était signé à doha le 29
février entre les américains et les
talibans kaboul n'y a pas participé
pourquoi l'absence des autorités
afghanes
oui c'était effectivement un vis-à-vis
entre américains et talibans qui avaient
qui avait contrarié la partie afghane
puisque achraf rani considéré qu'il
était marginalisé à juste titre puisque
c'était le cas et que ça ne sai pompe et
qu'éventuellement la suite du processus
mais c'était une condition aussi qui
avait été mise par les talibans qui
voulaient qui contient toujours
considéré que le gouvernement afghan et
un gouvernement fantoche et qu'il
n'avait pas discuté avait avec lui et
que son principal interlocuteur de
mettre impérativement les américains il
n'empêche que dans le cadre du processus
il y avait quand même cette étape de
négociations
un travail gagnent qui quitte à un casse
se met en place malgré tout et c'est
effectivement les enjeux principal
aujourd'hui puisque le retrait américain
et plus ou moins accès échéance est donc
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la de
la forme que prendra la transition après
le départ des américains
alors est ce que vous estimez que la
actuellement il ya des signes
d'apaisement qui vont permettre de
reprendre sereinement les négociations
intra de gan c'est un peu contradictoire
parce que les talibans ont renoncé à
leurs attaques contre les forces de la
coalition de international mais elles
ont maintenu les attaques sur les
troupes du gouvernement
d'ailleurs on peut rappeler qu'il ya eu
quelque 3500 soldats du gouvernement
tuant cinq mois ce qui montre que il ya
une intensification des attaques des
talibans contre les forces
gouvernementales ont ils trouvent que
les américains les etats-unis
maintiennent leur soutien au moins
aérien justement aux forces
gouvernementales donc c'est assez
contradictoire et d'ailleurs ça fait
l'objet de critiques d'un ancien chef
taliban avec tous la gombe dada qui
considère qu effectivement il ya une
l'engagement américain de ce point de
vue là mais ne s'est pas démentie donc
c'est contradictoire mais en même temps
le processus est lancé et malgré les
difficultés qui se font jour
il est vraisemblable qu'il ira de
l'avant par delà les obstacles qui
pourront se présenter
david rigoulet roze merci je rappelle
que vous êtes chercheur à l'ifas et
lérys et rédacteur en chef de la revue
aux réunions stratégiques merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct